a group of ukrainian orphans are due to
arrive in the uk later today aged
between 2 and 19 they will be traveling
from poland to london before making
their way up to scotland later in the
week where arrangements have been made
for their care
joining us in the studio ian blackford's
uh leader of the snp of course in
westminster mr blackford good to have
you on the program lovely to see you in
this video this time um let's talk about
this tell us exactly how you got
involved in this and what it is that
you're hoping to achieve well i mean
hibernian football club played a
football game in 2005. there's been a
long association since then of the
charity nepal kids giving support to a
number of orphan homes and stephen carr
and his team decided when the war broke
out that they wanted to help and they
wanted to make sure that the children
could be given sanctuary for now
in scotland so i got involved to help
them to get the necessary approvals
from the home office and i'm grateful
for the support that eventually we've
had from from everyone and this is just
such a fantastic story of 50 people that
can get sanctuary can have the chance to
get on with their lives and safety but
there is i think a message out of this
as well neil is that everyone's come
together to protect these children we
need to make sure that there are roots
for sanctuary for other children that
need our support as well
just tell us then a little bit about the
the children that are coming across as i
understand it today they're going to get
to london and then make their way to
scotland what awaits them when they get
to scotland then well they're going to
go into accommodation outside edinburgh
for the first two or three weeks let
them settle in in scotland make sure
that they're properly supported and then
they're going to be coming into
edinburgh but so many people have got
behind all of this
the local authorities in scotland the
scottish government the football club
themselves these children are going to
get a warm scottish welcome scottish
hospitality and fully supported for all
the time that they need to be here
before it's safe for them to return to
ukraine
anecdotally i've seen plenty of reports
that there are any number of orphans in
ukraine at the moment it appears to be a
bit of an issue do we have any rough
idea of kind of how many there are there
that are still needing to be brought out
of the country well i mean there have
been various reports but i think the
figure that has been used has been a
figure as many as 10 000.
um i think you know one of the important
things is we're doing this today and i'm
really grateful to the likes of lord
harrington and kevin foster that have
helped us over the course of the last
few days but we're debating a bill
tomorrow that will criminalize refugees
and i want to say to conservative mps
just think about this just think about
the humanity that we're all showing
today let's make sure that we all of us
we all do our bit to make sure that we
welcome vulnerable people we did this
before the second world war with the
kinder transport that people often talk
about let's make sure that that
generosity that welcome
that sanctuary that people need at a
time such as this is something that we
can all be proud of so does this all
mean that you'll be doing a david
cameron then and popping yourself behind
the wheel and heading out there to the
front line or close to the front line
well look it's not it's not about me or
anyone else i think really we've got to
do what we can to to help and i think
myself my colleagues lots of other
people will want to do that but most
importantly it's about being a voice for
those that needed help being a voice to
help the the charity the neighbor kids
charity in this case but let's make sure
this is not the end of it but this is
the beginning of it and then we continue
to support those that neither we are
we're all watching the horrors unfolding
we've seen what's happening in mario
paul which is just just devastating to
see what's going on
we need to make sure there are safe
routes out for young people for families
that need our support i i suspect given
your position you're on the opposition
benches you're not in government but i
suspect your position means that you
might feel slightly freer than that the
health secretary was on the program this
morning we have now heard from a number
of very senior officials well senior
figures within ukraine senior figures
outside of ukraine that vladimir putin
is a war criminal and the acts of
genocide are being committed you can
feel comfortable saying well one of the
things i actually raised at prime
minister's questions a few weeks ago
that we need to change our own law to
reflect on acts of aggression i mean
it's clear that we need to go after the
perpetrators of these crimes there are
legal niceties in terms of the
definition of genocide these are
unspeakable crimes for a man that's
slaughtering innocent civilians in
ukraine that's all we need to know and
this man and his regime
need to be held to account but let's to
conclude let's talk about the orphans
that are coming across and like you do
not have to be a parent to to look at
the scenes you know in mario paul and
elsewhere where babies bodies are being
pulled from the rubble you don't have to
be a parent to find that morally
important but i suspect that there will
be plenty of parents
who would wish to help those children
that aren't lucky enough to have parents
how can they well i think people can
obviously register through the uk
government site and of course they can
tick the box if they're in scotland for
the
the super sponsors people want to do
this people want to help government
needs to make sure it can move at pace
we're facing war in europe
none of us ever thought we'd be seeing
this seeing europeans are being bombed
people are having to flee war
we need to do all that we can and we
need to make sure that we get people
should we have seen it should we have
seen it given what given what happened
to 2014 and even before
should we not have seen this coming i
think there have been
policy failures over the course of the
the last few years of course they are
but we are where we are now we need to
make sure that we're supporting the
ukrainians to the fullest extent with
the military support that's been given
to them that needs to go as far and as
fast as we can the humanitarian support
what counts today is the ukrainian
people and the way that they're
suffering from the bombardment of their
country
well we wish you the best of luck with
the kids coming across and maybe speak
to you once they've settled in up in
edinburgh for now in blackburn thanks
for joining us thank you